why don't we do an oculus two giveaway
how about we do that okay an oculus two
giveaway literally if you give twenty
dollars to the super chat which we've
already said if we get to ten thousand
dollar ten thousand live
we'll give away ten thousand dollars
matter of fact here's what i'm gonna do
if we get to 7 500 live i'll give away
an ethereum how about that i'll give one
ethereum away to anybody if we get to 7
500 is that okay with you hey that's out
here
but to participate you gotta do a twenty
dollar super chat
so okay so let's do one right now right
now right now what we're doing right now
we're gonna do the what do you call it
we're gonna do the oculus 2 virtual
reality giveaway with a signed book so
adam not adam sambel if you want to put
that up so we can take a look at it it's
the next giveaway
can we give a quick shout out to kai
he's misspelled nothing today on
fire first of all he hasn't been asked
to spell anything there we go give him
too much you're zero for zero
ego you got noise there we go
all right so jose is the last winner
let's see what we got let's see how many
names it's gonna be now check this out
look at it boom put it
here we go baby
who is it
2
i guess we will never see you in the
game there's gonna be a lot of
procedures
i don't know
gerard wins oculus two that's it
gerard's porn experience about to change
okay so oculus two
this seems a little scripted right now i
don't know
good thing it wasn't the ps5 again
[Laughter]
okay well listen we keep going so now
gerard's out of it what are the chances
of one of the guys to win the game
gerard gave ten thousand dollars to be
in there a bunch of times
all right so gerard no audrey david no
tiki no launching let's continue guys if
you want to be in the next uh uh uh
raffle that we're doing super chat 20
bucks we're getting a lot of rigged
comments right now
we're getting a lot of risks
500.
it's not rigged it's fortified so okay
we get to 7 500 it will be and ethereum
we'll get to 10 000 it's ten thousand
dollars cash but we only have an hour
and 20 minutes left i can't believe that
2016
this is an insurrection at its finest
right now let's this is january six come
to life gerard winning the oculus
together strong
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]